block formerly known as square is a 50
billion fintech company they literally
pioneered so much of what we know at the
intersection of finance and technology
now naturally if you're at that
intersection bitcoin cryptocurrencies
that ends up being a place where you pay
attention now we know that jack dorsey
is a huge proponent of bitcoin and
nothing else really and as they continue
to push further further into bitcoin
cash app has an entire business line
that is dependent on bitcoin and the
ability to help their customers buy and
sell the digital currency now earlier
this week block put out a report bitcoin
knowledge and perceptions for their 2022
bitcoin report and i gotta say it was
chock full of great information i've
pulled three specific data points that i
think are worth paying attention to the
first here is that people with lower
incomes recognize the utility of bitcoin
as they state that people that have
those below average incomes they more
frequently note that bitcoin's a good
way to send money or to buy goods and
services than people who have above
average incomes basically the way to
think about this is rich people they use
bitcoin as a speculation tool they want
to actually invest in it they want to
make money they think of things like
inflation hedges etc but if you're in a
lower income bracket you simply want the
utility you want to be able to save you
want to be able to send and you want to
be able to spend as much as possible
with as little friction as possible and
that's exactly what this block report
goes ahead and highlights is that the
higher income folks they look at it as
speculation and investment lower income
folks they continue to seek out the
utility that a digital currency that
doesn't have middlemen allows for it
then if we move on to the second data
point here we can see that on a country
by country basis there's also a similar
breakdown first is countries like
nigeria vietnam india they have a very
high need for remittances and the appeal
of bitcoin to send money to other people
cross-border ends up being seen in those
countries if you're actually receiving
lots of remittances or you're sending
lots of remittances then of course
something like bitcoin becomes quite
attractive it's much lower fees than
anything else especially places like
western union and so naturally nigeria
vietnam and india all claiming yes
bitcoin is useful for remittances then
if we go look at lower income nations
that see the value of bitcoin as a means
of transacting guess what same countries
china vietnam nigeria india south africa
argentina all of these countries where
people that have lower incomes they want
to figure out how to use bitcoin from a
utility standpoint which is directly in
contrast to the western world narrative
of bitcoin simply being an investment
asset bitcoin has investment properties
to it you can buy it and it can go up in
us dollar value or it can go down but
people around the world the seven plus
billion people not in the united states
they're using bitcoin from a utility
standpoint they want to actually be able
to save it spend it or send it and those
three things are part of bitcoin's value
proposition now lastly if we go ahead
and we take a look well bitcoin has an
inflation hedge guess who understands
that countries with high inflation not
really that's surprising but argentina
is literally off the charts they've got
about 50 annual inflation so of course
they look for things that can actually
protect them from that inflation nigeria
india south africa many other countries
as well and so naturally what we get is
that people in the united states people
in the western developed world bitcoin
is a speculation tool for many of them
they see that it has volatility that it
could go up a lot or down a lot they
want to trade it they want to own it
they want to simply use it to make more
money there's nothing wrong with that
but we have to remember that the bulk of
people around the world they're not
looking for an investment they're
looking for safety they're looking for
utility if you have high inflation you
want an inflation hedge bitcoin serves
great for that over the last two years
it's outperformed stocks bonds
currencies and real estate and other
commodities and so naturally if bitcoin
can serve as that inflation hedge and
people are holding it then they want to
be able to save in it they want to be
able to spend it for goods and services
and they want to be able to send it
whether inside their country or across
borders bitcoin continues to gain
adoption and every single underlying
fundamental continues to grow up and to
the right yes the price is down but the
utilities up and people around the world
are starting to wake up and realize